Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. We still talk about the British conquering India, but that phrase disguises a more sinister reality. It wasn't the British government that seized India at the end of the 18th century, but a dangerously unregulated private company headquartered in one small office five windows wide in London and managed in India by an unstable sociopath.
感谢您收听《历史的余味》（The Rest Is History）。如需每周额外剧集、无广告收听、抢先观看系列节目以及加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请前往 therestishistory.com 加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。我们常谈论英国征服印度，但这一说法掩盖了一个更阴险的现实。18世纪末夺取印度的并非英国政府，而是一家危险且缺乏监管的私营公司，其总部位于伦敦一间仅有五扇窗户的小办公室里，在印度则由一名不稳定的反社会人格者管理。
The East India Company was a model of corporate efficiency. A hundred years into its history, it had only 35 permanent employees in its head office. Nevertheless, that skeleton staff executed a corporate coup unparalleled in history. The military conquest, subjugation and plunder The words of the historian William Dalrymple, talking about the East India Company. Tom Holland, William Dalrymple, I believe, is a man you know well. He is a great hero of mine, a wonderful man and more germainly from the point of view of this podcast, a wonderful historian whose books, The Anarchy, White Moguls, Return of a King, The Last Mogul, anyone interested in Indian or British history, I'm sure will have come across. And if they haven't't then they're very lucky because they've just been issued in a wonderful bumper pack the company quartet um willie is with us
东印度公司是企业效率的典范。在其成立一百年后，总部仅有35名正式员工。然而，这支精简的员工队伍却执行了一场历史上前所未有的企业政变。军事征服、征服与掠夺——这是历史学家威廉·达尔林普尔（William Dalrymple）谈论东印度公司时所用的词汇。汤姆·霍兰（Tom Holland），威廉·达尔林普尔，我相信你很了解他。他是我的一位大英雄，一个了不起的人，而且从本播客的角度来看，更重要的是，他是一位出色的历史学家。他的著作《无政府状态》（The Anarchy）、《白莫卧儿》（White Moguls）、《王者归来》（Return of a King）、《末代莫卧儿》（The Last Mogul），我相信任何对印度或英国历史感兴趣的人都读过。如果还没读过，那他们很幸运，因为这些书刚刚被打包成一套精彩的“公司四部曲”合集。威利，欢迎你。
absolutely thrilled to have you i hope he's pleased with your with your plug i'm very pleased well i i promised him a massive plug and i'm i'm more than happy to apply it was conditional it was my appearance is conditional on a massive plug will I'm more than happy to apply. It was conditional. It was conditional. My appearance was conditional on a massive plug. Willie, was that a big enough plug? It was big enough. If you want to carry on plugging, I won't stop. Well, no, I've got an additional plug because... Oh, well, go for it.
非常高兴你能来，希望他对你的宣传感到满意。我非常满意。好吧，我答应过他会大力宣传，我非常乐意这样做。这是有条件的，我的出场是以大力宣传为条件的。威利，这个宣传够大吗？够大了。如果你想继续宣传，我不会阻止。好吧，我还有一个额外的宣传，因为……哦，好吧，尽管说吧。
You are being recorded here on Zoom because your phone cannot cope with... You've deleted the app because you've got so many photographs on it and the reason you've got so many photographs on it is obviously you're a great photographer and one other plug willie's exhibition of photographs uh the traveler's eye is open at the grosvenor gallery in london at the moment so willie i feel i've paid my dues you have done so hard there must be a butt coming now there's a massive there's a massive part because like like um like can i just go now like the going's good like a british merchant eyeing up the riches of the east i have paid my dues and now i want to
你现在正在Zoom上被录音，因为你的手机无法处理……你删除了应用程序，因为里面照片太多了，而照片太多的原因显然是因为你是一位伟大的摄影师。还有一个宣传，威利的摄影展《旅行者的眼睛》（The Traveler's Eye）目前正在伦敦的格罗夫纳画廊（Grosvenor Gallery）展出。所以威利，我觉得我已经尽了我的义务。你确实做到了。现在肯定要转折了，有一个巨大的转折，因为就像……我可以现在就走吗？就像一个盯着东方财富的英国商人，我已经尽了我的义务，现在我想……
extort from you i want to extort your knowledge of the East India Company, which is the subject of our podcast episode today. As you say, I mean, it is a stunning story. It's so peculiar. A private company basically taking over the richest, most venerable land in the world. I mean, it's absolutely weird when you think about it. You've written about it for 20 years. Do you still find it odd when you contemplate it? I find it even odder, actually, at the end of 20 years than I did at the beginning, because like all historians of the East India Company, you still have that Victorian shadow lurking somewhere in your mind that sees this as something done by the British and it has this nationalist feeling to this story because so much of what has been written up until the
从你这里榨取知识，榨取你对东印度公司的了解，这也是我们今天播客的主题。正如你所说，这是一个令人震惊的故事。它太奇特了。一家私营公司基本上接管了世界上最富有、最古老的土地。当你想到这一点时，这绝对是不可思议的。你已经研究它20年了，当你思考它时，你仍然觉得它很奇怪吗？事实上，20年后我反而觉得它更奇怪了。因为像所有东印度公司的历史学家一样，你的脑海中总会潜伏着维多利亚时代的阴影，认为这是英国人所为，这个故事带有一种民族主义色彩，因为在此之前所写的大部分内容……
modern times sees it as a national story, the story of the British conquest of India. And the fact that it was a bunch of merchants and a bunch of very corrupt merchants who were who were recognized at the time as quite spectacularly corrupt and badly mannered and uh uh sort of uh an embarrassment to the nation uh and it's extraordinary rather encouraging to see how much the newspapers of the time excoriate the return nabobs uh up and down the land local local newspapers whether in shropshire or yorkshire or cornwall uh or east anglia and i've had great fun getting them all out and and reading them all unite in horror uh at these sort of and and partly it's a snobbery partly it's very much the same set of english prejudices that were directed against merchant bankers and hedge fund managers
现代时期将其视为一个民族故事，即英国征服印度的故事。事实上，这是一群商人，而且是一群在当时就被公认为极其腐败、举止粗鲁、对国家而言是一种尴尬的商人。看到当时的报纸如何抨击那些回国的“纳瓦布”（nabobs），真是令人惊讶且相当令人鼓舞。无论是在什罗普郡、约克郡、康沃尔还是东安格利亚，当地报纸都对他们表示惊恐。我很高兴能把这些资料找出来阅读，他们对这些人的恐惧是一致的。这部分是因为势利，部分是因为这与针对商业银行家和对冲基金经理的英国式偏见非常相似。
um of the sort who would crash their porsches into expensive city restaurants English prejudices that were directed against merchant bankers and hedge fund managers of the sort who would crash their Porsches into expensive city restaurants. And there's a feeling that these guys have got ill-gotten wealth, that they haven't worked for it, that they haven't been educated, they don't know how to behave. And there's all that set of prejudices. But there's also, perhaps surprisingly, some real indignation at what they were doing to India. And it's not just at the top end. It's not just Horace Walpole sitting in Twickenham, harrumphing into his diary.
那些会把保时捷撞进昂贵城市餐厅的人。针对商业银行家和对冲基金经理的英国式偏见，即那些会把保时捷撞进昂贵城市餐厅的人。人们有一种感觉，这些人拥有不义之财，他们没有为此努力工作，没有受过教育，不知道如何举止得体。所有这些偏见都存在。但也许令人惊讶的是，人们对他们对印度所做的事情也感到真正的愤慨。这不仅仅是在高层，不仅仅是霍勒斯·沃波尔（Horace Walpole）坐在特威克纳姆（Twickenham）的日记里发牢骚。
You get it up and down the land. Protests against particularly Clive and the Bengal famine and plays are put on in the Haymarket where Clive is satirised as Lord Vulture. So it was something that was known at the time, but somehow in the 19th century it became a national story. And then in India it became an anti-colonial nationalism, obviously, that the East India Company was just seen as an arm of the evil British Empire. And in Indian historiography too it's talked of as the British. But it isn't any more than, you know,
这种抗议在全国各地都有。针对克莱夫（Clive）和孟加拉大饥荒的抗议，干草市场剧院（Haymarket）上演的戏剧中，克莱夫被讽刺为“秃鹫勋爵”（Lord Vulture）。所以这在当时是众所周知的，但不知何故，在19世纪，它变成了一个民族故事。然后在印度，它显然变成了一种反殖民民族主义，东印度公司被视为邪恶大英帝国的触角。在印度史学中，它也被称为“英国人”。但它不再是了，你知道……
Facebook is the Americans or Google is the Americans. It has American staff. It also has other people working for it. And to me, the kind of things that came through last, really, and I only realised as I was finishing the book, I think, was the extent to which not only was it coming out of one office with this initially skeleton staff, 35 people, a little bit before Classy,
就像Facebook代表美国人，或者Google代表美国人一样。它有美国员工，也有其他人为它工作。对我来说，真正显现出来的事情，我想是在我写完书时才意识到的，那就是它不仅源于一个最初只有35名员工的精简办公室，在克莱夫之前的一点时间里……
but it was just, it was an extraordinary shadow operation. Even in India, there were only 250 white people well into the 18th century in the administrative hub and the fighting of which there was a great deal was done by Indians. So you know of the East India Company army just in 1799 just as as Britain is rearming to meet Napoleon, is 200,000, which is exactly double the size of the British army, which is 100,000 men. And those are not white soldiers, you know, imported from the shires. Those are Indians trained up as mercenaries. And where's the money coming from to pay them? It's borrowed from Indian bankers. So it's the most extraordinary con operation in history
而且它只是一个非凡的影子行动。即使在18世纪，在印度的行政中心，白人也只有250人，而战斗（其中有很多战斗）是由印度人完成的。所以你知道，东印度公司的军队在1799年，就在英国重新武装以应对拿破仑时，有20万人，这正好是英国军队（10万人）规模的两倍。那些不是从英国乡村进口的白人士兵，而是被训练成雇佣兵的印度人。支付他们的钱从哪里来？是从印度银行家那里借来的。所以这是历史上最非凡的诈骗行动。
that Indians were persuaded to finance and die for the sake of a British company and British shareholders. And also what's lovely about it is that, you know, in this rising din of the debate on empire and colonialism, the, you know. There are various claims made by the likes of Nigel Biggar and so on for what the empire did and bringing civilization and the generosity of the empire builders and all that line of argument. The great thing about the East India Company is none of that washes at all because the company is very clearly there only to make a profit.
印度人竟然被说服去资助并为一家英国公司和英国股东而死。而且令人欣慰的是，在关于帝国和殖民主义的辩论声浪中……像奈杰尔·比格（Nigel Biggar）等人对帝国所做的事情、带来的文明以及帝国建设者的慷慨等论点提出了各种主张。东印度公司的伟大之处在于，这些论点完全站不住脚，因为公司显然只是为了盈利。
They don't pretend to be about anything else. I mean, no one joins Goldman Sachs to feed the starving of Africa. And the East India Company was the Goldman Sachs of its day. You joined it to make a fortune. Most people didn't. Most people died young. But if they lived until their 30s
他们并不假装是为了其他任何事情。我的意思是，没有人加入高盛是为了养活非洲的饥民。而东印度公司就是那个时代的“高盛”。你加入它是为了发财。大多数人没有成功。大多数人英年早逝。但如果他们活到30多岁……
and came home, the chances are they could come home and build a gorgeous paladian mansion, which is now in the hands of the National Trust. So, Willie, let's backtrack a bit let's let's give a bit of context i've given i've given a bit of a fast forward there but no no no don't worry um so we've got lots of questions from listeners so tim wright asks a question which should probably start with he says when it was set up did the east inclead company have a clear vision a company ethos and did it change over time or maybe we
并回到家乡，他们很可能可以回来建造一座华丽的帕拉第奥式豪宅，现在这些豪宅掌握在国家信托基金（National Trust）手中。所以，威利，让我们回顾一下，让我们提供一点背景。我刚才做了一个快速回顾，但别担心。我们有很多听众的问题，蒂姆·赖特（Tim Wright）问了一个问题，我们可能应该从这里开始。他说，东印度公司成立时，是否有明确的愿景、公司精神？它是否随时间而改变？或者也许我们……
can deal with the change over time later on. But talk to us about, so when is it set up, and who are they, and what do they want? So the East India Company, when it's set up, is really a completely different beast in every single way from the heyday of the East India Company from Plassey onwards, 1765. When the company is set up the first meetings take place in 1599 which is the year that Shakespeare is writing Hamlet and they happen in this you know just a mile away from the Globe Theatre in a now lost building called Moorgate Hall in Moorgate Fields. When that happens Britain has no empire. There are the first colonies being set up very shakily in Virginia. You have
可以稍后再处理随时间变化的问题。但请告诉我们，它是什么时候成立的，他们是谁，他们想要什么？所以，东印度公司在成立时，与1765年普拉西战役（Plassey）之后的鼎盛时期相比，在各个方面都是完全不同的野兽。当公司成立时，第一次会议于1599年举行，那一年莎士比亚正在写《哈姆雷特》，会议地点就在离环球剧院（Globe Theatre）一英里远的地方，在一座现在已经消失的建筑里，叫摩尔门大厅（Moorgate Hall）。那时，英国还没有帝国。弗吉尼亚州正在摇摇欲坠地建立第一批殖民地。你有……
the first Protestant colonies arriving and being knocked back in Ireland and the rich boys on the block are the Spanish and the Portuguese, who are successfully plundering Incas and Aztecs and shipping gold from Colombia and all the rest of it. And the British at this point are very much on the rim of Europe, ephemeral. They've just cut themselves off from the most powerful force in Europe, not the EC, but the papacy in the 16th century.
第一批新教殖民者到达并在爱尔兰受挫，而当时最有钱的玩家是西班牙人和葡萄牙人，他们成功地掠夺了印加人和阿兹特克人，并从哥伦比亚等地运送黄金。而英国人此时正处于欧洲的边缘，转瞬即逝。他们在16世纪刚刚切断了与欧洲最强大力量——不是欧盟，而是教皇——的联系。
And they're on their own. And what do they do? They turn with sort of piratical enthusiasm to what is politely called privateering. And they're licensed to go out and raid Portuguese and Spanish shipping. And this is what happens. So this is the spirit of Drake and Raleigh.
他们孤立无援。他们做了什么？他们以一种海盗般的热情转向了所谓的“私掠”（privateering）。他们被授权去袭击葡萄牙和西班牙的船只。这就是发生的事情。所以这就是德雷克（Drake）和罗利（Raleigh）的精神。
Absolutely. And the actual first ship, which is renamed the Red Dragon to make it sound like a nice pub near you in Chalk Valley, Tom, was originally called the Scourge of Malice. And it was a pirate ship. It's literally, you know, Jolly Rogers, all that. And a lot of the sailors were clearly clearly they actually described themselves in the initial meeting of the East India Company, which we've got full notes and a list of everyone that turned up in their profession.
绝对是。实际上第一艘船，被重新命名为“红龙号”（Red Dragon），听起来像你家附近的一家不错的酒吧，汤姆，它最初叫“恶意之鞭”（Scourge of Malice）。那是一艘海盗船。字面上就是，你知道，骷髅旗，所有那些东西。很多水手显然……他们实际上在东印度公司的最初会议上描述了自己，我们有完整的记录和所有参加者的名单以及他们的职业。
And they described themselves as privateers. They were pirates. They were, you know, the the the Tom Hollander figure, as opposed to the tom holland uh in uh in pirates of the caribbean and so the merchants who are doing it they're kind of pooling resources because this is a very risky venture is that right so it's a hugely risky venture uh it had absolutely no prospect of uh of initial success uh and uh the earlier voyage that sir james lester, the original sea captain who led the first voyage, had sunk and all his crew had been eaten by cannibals. I mean, you couldn't have put your money on a less likely venture. And Willie, just one thing. Also, the East Indies is not India at this point, is it? it's kind of indonesia they're not they're not the great trade of the east india company in the peak period uh that we're talking about the the the trades that generated uh the
他们称自己为私掠者。他们是海盗。他们是，你知道，汤姆·霍兰德（Tom Hollander）式的人物，而不是《加勒比海盗》里的汤姆·霍兰（Tom Holland）。所以那些商人，他们是在汇集资源，因为这是一项风险极高的冒险，对吗？是的，这是一项风险极高的冒险。它最初完全没有成功的希望。而且，最初带领第一次航行的詹姆斯·兰开斯特爵士（Sir James Lancaster）之前的航行沉没了，他所有的船员都被食人族吃掉了。我的意思是，你不可能把钱押在一项更不可能成功的冒险上。威利，还有一件事。而且，东印度群岛此时还不是印度，对吧？它更像是印度尼西亚。他们不是……东印度公司在鼎盛时期的大贸易，我们谈论的那些产生……
money that financed all this initially came from the textile trade with india but at the beginning neither textiles nor india were in the picture they were looking to trade in spices and in what we today would call indonesia um particularly this island of run where all the nutmeg came from which charles milton has written so wonderfully about in nathaniel's nutmeg so they're not aiming india they're not aiming at the indian uh textile trade they're aiming something completely different in a different part of the world and and as their pirates on the initial voyage, they see, even before they get there, a Portuguese ship coming the opposite direction.
最初资助这一切的钱来自与印度的纺织品贸易，但起初纺织品和印度都不在考虑范围内。他们寻求的是香料贸易，以及我们今天所说的印度尼西亚。特别是这个兰岛（Run），所有的肉豆蔻都来自那里，查尔斯·米尔顿（Charles Milton）在《纳撒尼尔的肉豆蔻》（Nathaniel's Nutmeg）中写得非常精彩。所以他们的目标不是印度，不是印度的纺织品贸易，他们的目标是世界另一端完全不同的东西。而且，作为最初航行中的海盗，他们甚至在到达之前，就看到一艘葡萄牙船只从相反方向驶来。
So they go into sort of auto-plunder mode, and they just literally, they jump on the ship, they transfer all the clothes, and that's it. And then they sail back. They fill that hole, and they sail home, and sell it for a million pounds. A job well done. It's a huge profit.
于是他们进入了某种“自动掠夺”模式，他们直接跳上船，把所有的衣服都搬走，就是这样。然后他们航行回来。他们填满了那个洞，航行回家，以一百万英镑的价格卖掉。干得漂亮。这是一笔巨大的利润。
And so that then sets up the, that's the kind of family. The next few voyages. Right. Yeah, but again They're not these guys are you know again not you know The best on the block at this and to their great irritation The Dutch who've been a little bit ahead of them and done a couple of voyages which actually sparked this off because it's the Dutch sailors coming to London and trying to buy London boats for this that get that rankles with
所以这就建立了……那是某种家族模式。接下来的几次航行。对。是的，但同样，这些人不是……他们不是这方面的行家，令他们非常恼火的是，荷兰人比他们领先了一点，进行了几次航行，这实际上引发了这一切，因为是荷兰水手来到伦敦并试图购买伦敦的船只来做这件事，这让……
the kind of Shakespearean pride of Elizabethan well I think that's fair enough uh yeah that's fair enough absolutely so you can't have our ship so instead they so while the Dutch are still sitting waiting in their hotel uh the English merchants say have a little meeting and say we'll do our own and tell them to piss off I mean that's literally the authentic spirit of the city of london flourishing even though so but so willie you mentioned the dutch so so basically the dutch and the portuguese have already muscled in on this spice trade and and spanish yeah but but spanish are the other hemisphere but very much sailing around the same the mention of the dutch that they are kind of the proto-capitalists and the english they essentially are blazing a path that the english kind of the proto capitalists and the English they essentially
伊丽莎白时代那种莎士比亚式的骄傲感到恼火。好吧，我认为这很公平。是的，这很公平，绝对。所以你不能拥有我们的船，所以相反，当荷兰人还在酒店里等着的时候，英国商人开了一个小会说，我们要自己做，让他们滚蛋。我的意思是，这确实是伦敦城蓬勃发展的真实精神。所以，威利，你提到了荷兰人，所以基本上荷兰人和葡萄牙人已经挤进了这个香料贸易，还有西班牙人……是的，但西班牙人在另一个半球，但他们确实在同一个区域航行。提到荷兰人，他们是某种原始资本家，而英国人，他们本质上是在开辟一条道路，英国人……
are blazing a path that the English and then the British in due course will follow well yes and no because there's two important things so the the Dutch come up with the idea of um of a stock exchange which is later imported to to Britain and they come up with a lot of financial instruments which are brought over at the time of William of Orange. But the thing which the English seem to have come up with is the idea of the joint stock company. Oh, so that's ours. That's our invention.
他们正在开辟一条道路，英国人，然后是后来的英国，将会跟随。嗯，是也不是，因为有两件重要的事情。所以荷兰人想出了证券交易所的主意，后来被引入英国，他们想出了很多金融工具，是在威廉三世（William of Orange）时期带来的。但英国人似乎想出的东西是“股份制公司”的概念。哦，那是我们的。那是我们的发明。
That's ours. It's the Muscovy Company which the East India Company is 1599, but the Muscovy Company from memory is something like 1520. It's a good 60 years. So that's furs and stuff from Russia, presumably. Yeah, and that's furs and sable from the Volga and all this sort of thing. And then even that gets kind of diverted eastwards because due to various wars, a lot of the Muscovy merchants come back through Persia.
那是我们的。那是莫斯科公司（Muscovy Company），东印度公司是1599年的，但莫斯科公司凭记忆大约是1520年左右。那是整整60年。所以那是来自俄罗斯的毛皮之类的东西，大概。是的，那是来自伏尔加河的毛皮和黑貂皮，所有这些东西。然后即使是那样，也因为各种战争而转向东方，许多莫斯科商人通过波斯回来。
And that, again, sort of extends Elizabethan IA eastwards and then at what point Willie do they do they start to what so India is not in the picture at this point really not at all so at what point does India specifically enter the picture so it's rather like imagine uh a startup today and uh it's its initial offering uh is to do one thing in one place let's say do a podcast uh for historians for example that's a very good very good well chosen example and let's say just for the sake of argument the podcast is a complete failure no one listens this is a very badly chosen example then they decided instead to do videos on science fiction uh and that's rather what happens to these companies they they move from doing they they tried to get the
而这又将伊丽莎白时代的触角向东延伸。那么威利，他们在什么时候开始……印度此时并不在画面中，真的完全不在。那么印度具体是在什么时候进入画面的？这有点像想象今天的初创公司，它最初的产品是在一个地方做一件事，比如为历史学家做一个播客，这是一个非常好的例子。假设为了论证，这个播客完全失败了，没人听，这是一个非常糟糕的例子。然后他们决定改做科幻视频，这正是这些公司发生的事情。他们从做……
spices from indonesia but the dutch are just richer they got bigger ships they got better finance uh they've got much better finance that's ultimately the thing and they and various wars the famous and all this sort of thing goes on in the 1630s 40s and 50s and eventually the the the the english basically bail and there's already been a few exploratory voyages that have reached surat the mughal port on the coast of Gujarat, and also to Thata, which was the often forgotten Mughal port at the base of the Indus, and that's what they begin to focus. So they kind of relaunch in the 1640s, no longer about Indonesia, no longer about spices, it's now about textiles and India. And then there's one final change is that they basically migrate the bulk of their energy from the west coast of India where the Mughals were largely exporting and looking
他们试图从印度尼西亚获得香料，但荷兰人更富有，他们有更大的船，更好的资金。他们有更好的资金，这最终是关键。在1630年代、40年代和50年代发生了各种战争，著名的……所有这些事情都在发生，最终英国人基本上退出了。而且已经有几次探索性航行到达了苏拉特（Surat），即古吉拉特邦海岸的莫卧儿港口，以及塔塔（Thata），那是经常被遗忘的印度河口的莫卧儿港口，这就是他们开始关注的地方。所以他们在1640年代重新启动，不再关注印度尼西亚，不再关注香料，现在关注的是纺织品和印度。然后还有一个最终的变化，他们基本上将大部分精力从莫卧儿人主要出口和向西看的印度西海岸，转移到了胡格利河（Hukli），并建立了加尔各答。而加尔各答，奇怪的是，因为它潮湿、沼泽、疾病缠身，在任何人类意义上都非常不被看好，但它最终证明是巨大的摇钱树，因为那是生产最好纺织品的地方。到1700年左右，印度令人震惊地生产了世界GDP的40%，而当时英国大约是6%，抱歉，不是英国，是英格兰，大约是6%。所以威利。随着这种巨大的权力失衡……
westwards right round to the Hukli and they found Calcutta. And Calcutta, bizarrely, because it's damp, boggy, disease-ridden, and thoroughly unpromising in every human way, nonetheless proves to be the big money spinner, because that's where the best textiles are being produced. And by about 1700, India, astonishingly, is producing 40% of the world's GDP, at a time when the British are at about 6%, English, sorry, it's not Britain, it's England specifically, it's on about 6%. So Willie. And as the there's this huge imbalance of power in that the
莫卧儿人是最富有的，这是一个统一的国家，拥有一百万武装人员，组织非常严密，对违反规则的人有非常、非常令人不快的惩罚。伊丽莎白时代的人最初是以某种笨拙的经济移民身份进来的，恳求在这个非常、非常富有的国家做生意。我们经常认为……最后一点，我们认为莫卧儿人是那种把芒果放进嘴里、玩白鸽、通常与舞女嬉戏的颓废家伙，但所有这些都建立在一个非常强大的制造业基础上，这通常不是电影中莫卧儿人的形象。那里有一个巨大的原始工业机器在运转，特别是在孟加拉，
the moguls are the richest, it's a unified state with a million men under arms, very tightly and rigidly organised, very, very unpleasant punishments for those who break the rules. And the Elizabethans come in initially as sort of stumbling economic migrants pleading to do business in this very, very rich country country and so often we think of what just final that we think we think of the moguls as these sort of a feat guys dropping mangas into their mouths and playing with white pigeons and and and generally cavorting with dancing girls but all that is built on a very strong manufacturing base which is not part of the usual movie picture of the moguls there's a massive uh proto-industrial machine going in, particularly in Bengal,
那里有一百万织布工，制造着世界上最伟大的纺织品。这些纺织品种类繁多。有非常精致的透明丝绸，还有你在许多国家信托基金豪宅中看到的作为床罩和挂毯的华丽刺绣。但真正的……你在许多国家信托基金豪宅中看到的作为床罩和挂毯的华丽刺绣，但真正的……贸易的支柱是世界上质量最好、价格最便宜的棉花，它们以大块生产，称为“件装货”（piece goods），这些东西直接被塞进东印度公司的船上。问题是竞争非常激烈。
where there's one million weavers making the greatest textiles in the world. And those textiles are from a whole variety of different sorts. There are very fancy transparent silks and really gorgeous embroideries that you see up in a lot of National Trust houses as bedspreads and hangings. But the real sort of bread and butter embroideries that you see up in a lot of national trust houses as bedspreads and hangings but the real uh sort of uh bread and butter of the trade is the cheapest best quality cotton in the world that's produced in large in large blocks called called peace uh peace goods and these are just you know shoved straight onto east india company uh boats the problem is there's a lot of competition
但好消息是，竞争实际上并没有来自印度。印度人在孟加拉湾等地做一些当地贸易，偶尔去海湾，但大规模的出口贸易从整个制造业繁荣开始就一直掌握在欧洲人手中。威利，我一直有一个问题，你是最适合回答的人。英国人，正如你所说，基本上是伟大的帝国宫廷总是吸引的那种野蛮人。印度一直是一个极其富有的文明。野蛮人，通常来自草原，通过开伯尔山口（Khyber Pass）或其他地方下来，他们不断地入侵。就像维京人来到君士坦丁堡的瓦兰吉卫队（Varangian Guard）等等。所以英国人在某种意义上只是来到伟大国王宫廷的野蛮人。
but the good thing is none of the competition is really coming from india uh the indians do a bit of local trade across the bay of bengal and so on a little bit across to uh to the gulf but the large-scale export trade always remains in european hands from the beginning of this whole manufacturing boom willie a question i have always had um and you were the person to answer it. The English, as you say, are, I mean, basically, they're the kind of barbarians who great imperial courts have always attracted. India has always been this incredibly rich civilization. Barbarians, usually from the, you know, from the steppes coming down through Khyber Pass or whatever, you know, they've endlessly invaded. So the Vikings coming to the Baragian Guard in Constantinople and all that. So the English in that sense are just, you know, they're barbarians coming to the court of a great king.
但正如你所说，莫卧儿帝国也是一个伟大的经济强国，它生产所需的一切。那么英国人用什么来购买这些纺织品呢？这正是问题所在。尽管有很多非常乐观的尝试，比如向孟加拉人推销粗花呢，这正是你所需要的，一套三件套西装，然后他们进行了第二轮尝试，试图把粗花呢当作马毯卖，即使那样也不太受欢迎。所以归根结底，答案是：什么都没有。他们不需要英国的任何东西。他们很高兴偶尔收到伊丽莎白时代的马车作为礼物，或者小号，他们相当喜欢……
But as you say, the Mughal Empire is also a great economic power and it produces everything that it needs so what are the english using to buy these textiles well this is exactly the the issue because uh despite a lot of very optimistic attempts to sell the bengalis tweed for example just what you need a three-piece suit and then they then they have a second round they try selling the tweeters horse blankets and even that doesn't go down very well um so at the end of the day the answer is nothing they don't want anything from england they're quite happy to have the occasional sort of uh elizabethan coach or something given as a present or trumpets for them they rather like
珀塞尔（Purcell）风格的小号乐曲等等。一个叫罗伯特·特鲁利（Robert Truly）的人叛逃了，我认为他是第一个从东印度公司叛逃的人，他去担任小号手。但就真正的经济贸易而言，这不是商品的交换，因为坦率地说，没有什么可交换的。所以他们买这些东西只是用银币，这顺便说一下，与罗马时代的情况完全不同。当罗马人来到印度时，印度人想要各种各样的东西，比如橄榄油和葡萄酒，以及他们可以实际交易的一系列商品。但在18世纪，这些公司的情况并非如此。所以他们所做的就是带黄金。
sort of Purcell style trumpet voluntaries and and all that and a guy called Robert Truly defects is what I think the first defector from the East India Company who goes over to service as a trumpeter but in terms of proper economic trade it isn't an exchange of goods because there is frankly nothing so how they buy this stuff just with a silver coin or which which incidentally is quite different from from the situation in roman times when the romans came to uh to india there were all sorts of things that the indians wanted for the romans like olive oil and wine and a whole range of goods that they could actually trade in but that's not the case in the 18th century with these companies. So what they do is they just bring gold.
黄金从欧洲流入印度，黄金和白银。有趣的是，印度在矿产和自然资源方面并没有太多这些东西。印度有珠宝，有各种好东西，但没有大量的黄金。也没有大量的白银。所以莫卧儿人很高兴这样做。
And gold flows from Europe into India, gold and silver. Neither of which, funnily enough, India has a great deal of, in terms of mines and natural resources, India has jewels, has all sorts of good things, but it doesn't have a great deal of gold. Right. Nor does it have a great deal of silver. So the Mughals are very happy to do this.
但英国议会对此一点也不高兴，因为很快就很清楚，这个国家正在为奢侈品耗尽其黄金和白银储备，这正是普林尼（Pliny）在公元一世纪时的抱怨，他说所有想要丝绸和珠宝的罗马女士正在耗尽罗马国库。这在詹姆斯一世时期的英国发生得更多。好吧，所以这是亚当·斯密（Adam Smith）之前的时代。所以这是一种重商主义的方法，即你不是赢家就是输家。但我猜……好吧，亚当·斯密就在附近，看着并写着关于这家公司的文章，他厌恶这家公司。
But the English Parliament is not at all happy about this because very soon it becomes clear that the the country is literally draining uh its reserves of gold and silver for fancy luxuries which is exactly the complaint that plinny had in the first century when he says all the roman ladies wanting silks and jewels is draining the Roman treasury. This happens far more in Jacobean England. OK, so this is pre-Adam Smith. So it's kind of mercantilist approach that you're either a winner or a loser. But I guess... Well, Adam Smith is very much around and looking at and writing about the company, which he abhors.
这是一个非常有趣的观点，亚当·斯密，经常被右翼奉为经济学的终极权威，认为该公司的垄断是经济权力最令人震惊的滥用之一。他是该公司伟大的反对者之一，并希望它失去垄断地位。那么，威利，接下来发生了什么？在这一点上，莫卧儿人显然拥有这个奇妙的国家、
And it's a very interesting point that Adam Smith, who's often held up by the right as the last word in economics, thinks the company's monopoly is one of the most shocking abuses of economic power out there. And he is one of the great opponents of the company and wants it to lose its monopoly. So then, Willie, what happens? So at this point, clearly the Moughals have got this fantastic state,
制造业基础、庞大的军队。你知道，天平似乎向印度倾斜。没错。那么发生了什么改变了这一点？我以为这与波斯人有关，对吗？没错。这是一个完全的“外卡”（wild card），没有人预见到它。首先发生的是内部问题。莫卧儿帝国六代以来由杰出的……
manufacturing base, huge army. You know, the scales seem loaded in India's favour, as it were. Correct. So what happens to change that? And am I right in thinking it's something to do with the Persians? Correct. It's a complete wild card, and no one sees it coming. Well the first thing that happens is internal. The Mughals for six generations are led by remarkable
战士和战略家领导，他们缓慢地向南扩张。但最后一位，奥朗则布（Aurangzeb），最后一位伟大的莫卧儿皇帝，过度扩张，在战争上花费了太多钱。当他去世时，整个帝国开始崩溃。马拉塔人（Marathas），孟买上方山区的印度西部伟大战士，他们冲出了山脉。他们是印度教徒，对吧？他们是非常虔诚的印度教徒，在他们的领袖希瓦吉（Shivaji）的领导下，有意识地反对伊斯兰统治。这不仅仅是现代的插曲。在希瓦吉之后的一代人中，你得到了一些非常现代的、对伊斯兰统治的谴责。
warriors and strategists and they expand slowly south. But the final one, Aurangzeb, the final one of the great movies, over-expands dramatically and spends far too much money on war. And when he dies, the whole thing begins to clap. The Marathas, who are the great warriors of the west coast of India, in the hills above Bombay, they burst out of their hills. And they're Hindu, right? They are very Hindu and very consciously under their leader Shivaji opposed to Islamic rule. That isn't just a modern interpolation. You get from the generation after Shivaji some extraordinarily sort of modern sounding denunciations of Islamic rule.
这是一种非常有意识的印度教身份。我一直以为这是现代政治给他们贴上的标签，但事实上，桑杰·苏布拉马尼亚姆（Sanjay Subramaniam）挖掘出了很多听起来非常像RSS宣传的东西，可以追溯到希瓦吉死后仅一代人。所以非常有意识的印度教，非常回归印度古代，设计了具有大型吠陀、婆罗门祭祀等仪式的国王加冕仪式。这是一种有意识的、针对北方伊斯兰统治的本土主义起义。所以西海岸的那些人，德里和阿格拉之间的贾特人（Jats），旁遮普开始崛起的锡克教徒。所以整个帝国都在动摇，
And it's very consciously Hindu identity. I'd always assumed it was a modern political spin put on them, but in fact Sanjay Subramaniam has dug up a lot of stuff that sounds very much like RSS propaganda dating from one generation only after Shivaji's death. So very consciously Hindu, very much going back to Indian antiquity, designing kingship ceremonies which have the large Vedic, Brahminical sacrifices and this sort of stuff. And very consciously a nativist uprising against Islamic rule from the north. And so those guys in the West Coast, you've got the Jats between Delhi and Agra, you've got the Sikhs beginning to rise up in the Punjab. So the whole thing is shaking,
但基本上仍然控制着印度大部分地区，特别是控制着有钱的孟加拉。孟加拉的税收收入支付了莫卧儿帝国约三分之二的开支。所以即使印度其他地方都丢了，只要他们守住孟加拉，他们仍然有钱维持公务员和军队。然后，出乎意料地，波斯发生了一场我们今天所说的军事政变。萨法维王朝（Safavids），他们非常像是莫卧儿人的波斯对应物，
but basically still holding over most of India, particularly holding onto Bengal where the money is. It's the tax revenues of Bengal that pays for about two thirdsthirds of Mughal expenses. So even if the whole of the rest of India goes and they hold on to Bengal, they've still got the money to keep the civil service and the army going. Then, out of nowhere, there's what we today would call a military coup in Persia. And the Safavids, who are very much the kind of Persian equivalents of the Mughals,
建造伊斯法罕（Isfahan）的人，波斯的沙阿·阿巴斯（Shah Abbas），建造了至今仍矗立在伊斯法罕的那些华丽清真寺。那个王朝被一个非凡、相当冷酷的角色纳迪尔沙（Nadir Shah）消灭了。纳迪尔沙出身卑微，白手起家，他父亲在伊朗和阿富汗边境制作毛皮帽子。他进入军队，也是一位伟大的军事技术爱好者，他设计了一种轻型坦克炮的骑兵对应物，一种巨大的“加扎勒”（gazelle），由三脚架支撑在马脖子上，发射可以穿透任何莫卧儿盔甲的穿甲弹。1738年，他带着没有统治印度意图的军队从波斯出来。
the guys who built Isfahan, Shah Abbas in Persia, building these gorgeous mosques that still stand to this day in Isfahan. That dynasty is snuffed out by an extraordinary, rather grim character called Nadir Shah. And Nadir Shah is from very humble origins, self-made man, his dad made fur hats on the border of iran and afghanistan literally and he gets into the army and he is also a great military technology buff he designs a sort of the cavalry equivalent of a light tank gun a gazelle that's enormous and that's propped up on a horse's neck by a sort of tripod that fires armor-piercing slugs that can pierce any Mughal armor. And in 1738 he comes out of Persia with no intention of ruling India. It's
从一开始就很清楚，他想要的是莫卧儿的现金。为什么？为了与他真正的两个敌人——土耳其人和俄国人——作战。所以他进行了这次掠夺突袭，首先进入阿富汗，那是莫卧儿的领地。我们经常忘记莫卧儿帝国一直延伸到喀布尔。喀布尔是夏季首都。然后没有遇到任何抵抗，他继续前进。然后他占领了白沙瓦、拉合尔，最后到达了卡尔纳尔战役（Battle of Karnal）。他在卡尔纳尔战役中以出色的战略击败了150万莫卧儿军队，然后通过简单地邀请莫卧儿皇帝共进晚餐并逮捕他，俘虏了皇帝，并带着他进入了德里。六周后，他带着整个莫卧儿国库离开，孔雀宝座、光之海钻石（Koh-i-Noor）、光之山钻石（Dari-i-Noor），莫卧儿人六代以来掠夺、收集、开采和交易的一切，他装进6000辆马车，直接带回阿富汗和赫拉特。我的意思是，这就像……你可以想象莫卧儿帝国就像一面巨大的巴洛克式镜子，刚从三楼的窗户扔出来，
very clear from the beginning that what he wants is Mughal cash. Why? In order to fight his two real enemies who are the Turks and Russians. And so he goes on this looting raid, first into Afghanistan, which is a Mughal hell. We often forget that the Mughal empire stretches right up to Kabul. Kabul is a summer capital. And then meeting no resistance, he just carries on. Then he takes Peshawar, then Lahore and finally arrives at the Battle of Karnal. He defeats 1.5 million Mughal troops in a brilliant bit of strategy at the Battle of Karnal, then captures the Mughal emperor person by simply inviting him to dinner and arresting him and marches into Delhi with him. Six weeks later, he leaves with the entire Mughal treasury, the Peacock
它落在地上，碎成了数百万个闪闪发光的碎片。而那些闪闪发光的碎片就是印度的每一个城镇。所以焦特布尔（Jodhpur）宣布独立，斋浦尔（Jaipur）、乌代浦（Udaipur），拉贾斯坦邦所有那些华丽的城堡都是在这个时候建造的，因为没有人需要再向德里缴纳税款了。坦贾武尔（Tanjore）、海得拉巴（Hyderabad）。突然间，你曾经拥有一个拥有一百万武装人员的巨大超级国家，现在却变成了一个破碎的、微小的城邦散落体。而此时出现并试图吞并这些力量的，是两家东印度公司，竞争的英国和法国。完美。汤姆，我想我们现在应该休息一下。
throne, the Koh-i-Noor, the Dari-i-Noor, everything that the Mughals have plundered and collected and mined and traded for over six generations, he lifts into 6,000 wagons and takes it straight up to Afghanistan and Herat. And like, I mean, this is, you know, you could imagine the Mughal Empire like an enormous Baroque mirror that's just thrown out of a third-story window,
然后我们会回来，我们将讨论东印度公司的崛起……因为我们有普拉西战役等等。普拉西战役、克莱夫和沃伦·黑斯廷斯（Warren Hastings）。所有这些乐趣和游戏。所有这些即将到来，所以我们必须加快速度。我们要休息一下以补充能量，然后我们会很快回来，完成所有这些。好的，一会儿见。我是玛丽娜·海德（Marina Hyde），我是理查德·奥斯曼（Richard Osman），我们共同主持《历史的余味：娱乐篇》（The Rest Is Entertainment）。这是你每周的娱乐新闻、评论、演艺圈八卦的固定节目，
and it lands on the ground and it smashes into a million tiny glittering fragments. And those tiny glittering fragments are every town in India. So Jodhpur declares its independence, Jaipur, Udaipur, all those gorgeous castles in Rajasthan are built at this time because no one's having to send their taxes to Delhi anymore. Tanjore, Hyderabad. Suddenly, where you had one enormous megastate with a million men under arms, you suddenly have a fragment, a fragmentary scattering of tiny city states. And the two forces that emerge at this point to hoover that up are the two East Indy companies, the rival English and French. Perfect. Tom, I think we should take a break right now.
在我们的问答环节中，我们拉开了娱乐界的帷幕，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、额外剧集和抢先获得现场门票，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。欢迎回到《历史的余味》。我们正在与威廉·达尔林普尔讨论东印度公司。我们正面临着，用一个词来说，印度的“无政府状态”。
And then we'll come back and we'll have the East Indy companies rise to... Because we've got the Battle of Classy and all that coming. The Battle of Classy and Clive and Warren Hastings. All that fun and games. All that's coming, so we're going to have to speed up. We're going to take a break in order to replenish our energy and then we'll come back very very quickly and move through all this okay back in a sec i'm marina hyde and i'm richard osmond and together we host the rest is entertainment it's your weekly fix of entertainment news reviews splash of showbiz
莫卧儿帝国正处于内爆过程中。而东印度公司，一家商人公司，基本上停在这个垂死巨兽的侧翼。他们在孟加拉，那真的是……我的意思是，它是印度最富有的地区，对吧？可能是世界上最富有的地区。这是世界历史上仅有的两个印度产量超过中国的时刻之一。
gossip and on our q a we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com That's therestisentertainment.com Welcome back to The Rest Is History. We're talking the East India Company with Willie Dalrymple. And we are facing, to coin a word, anarchy in India.
它发生在遥远的古代，然后又发生在18世纪中期。好的，所以税收的征收非常重要，所以有一个关于这个叫赛义德·拉扎·汗（Saeed Raza Khan）的人的精彩描述，我想你提到过……他有时会把拖欠税款的官员和人关进一个坑里，里面装满了腐烂到充满蠕虫的废物。他还强迫他们穿上装满活猫的皮长裤，并强迫他们喝混合了盐的水牛奶。所以如果税务局的人在听，任何税务局的人在听这个节目……
The Mughal Empire is in a process of implosion. And the East India Company, a company of merchants, are basically parked on the flank of this expiring behemoth. They're in Bengal, which really is kind of really, I mean, it's the richest area in India, is it? Richest area in the world, probably. This is one of only two moments of world history that India is producing more than China.
让欠税者穿上装满活猫的皮长裤的想法是一个绝妙的主意。汤姆，我最近在Instagram上看到了你的猫，它看起来是一个非常安静的家伙，对主人打开约克郡饼干盒非常有耐心。不，那是另一只。那是母的那只。但公的那只，
It happened once in distant antiquity, and then it happens again in the mid-18th century. Okay, and so it's very important that uh the taxes are collected and so there's this magnificent description of this guy called saeed raza khan who i think you mentioned um who who would sometimes place airing officials and people who did not pay their taxes into a pit containing waste in such a state of putrefaction as to be full of worms he also used to oblige them to wear leather long drawers filled with live cats and he would force them to drink buffalo's milk mixed with salt so if the inland revenue were listening anyone from the inland revenue is listening in on
我的意思是，我们昨天录了一个播客，它实际上打断了我们。我知道威利在说哪个片段。是饼干茶。饼干茶，没错。好吧，我的意思是，那非常“东印度公司”，不是吗？这就是它的全部意义。所以，威利，本质上，莫卧儿人一直在运行这种剥削机制。说东印度公司基本上接管了它，在多大程度上是公平的？
this the idea of making tax defaulters wear leather long drawers filled with live cats is a is a brilliant one i recently saw your cat on Instagram, Tom, where he looked a very quiescent fellow who was extremely patient with his master opening boxes of Yorkshire cookies. No, that was even. That was the female one. But the male cat,
让逃税者穿上装满活猫的皮质长裤，这个主意真是太棒了。汤姆，我最近在Instagram上看到你的猫，它看起来是个非常安静的家伙，对主人打开约克郡饼干盒的行为极其耐心。不，那是母的那只。但公的那只，
I mean, we did a podcast yesterday and he interrupted us, actually. I know the clip Willie is talking about. It's the biscuit tea. The biscuit tea, exactly. Well, I mean, that's very East India Company, isn't it? That's that's what it's all about. So, Willie, essentially, there is this apparatus of exploitation that the moguls have been running. To what to what extent is it fair to say that basically the East Indian Company just take it over?
我的意思是，我们昨天录播客时它还打断了我们。我知道威利说的是哪个片段。就是那个饼干茶。没错，就是饼干茶。嗯，我的意思是，这非常有东印度公司的风格，不是吗？这正是它的核心所在。所以，威利，本质上，莫卧儿人一直在经营这种剥削机构。说东印度公司基本上接管了它，在多大程度上是公平的？
It's not as neat a comparison as one might like, because the Mughals, whether you take the right wing Indian view that they've been living in India since the 1200s, that they're as Indian as the Norman French are by the 18th century England, that they are fully integrated into India and this is their home. They rule for the long term and they invest in simple things that you need to do if you're an Indian ruler, in things grain stores so that you know everyone knows that monsoons fail once every few years and you need a stock of grain to feed your people they invest in in all sorts of long-term uh uh uh economic um investment which which a country needs what's notable about the beginning of East India Company rule is that not only do they, as you suggest, use the mogul tax system and draw wealth from that, which they do do extremely efficiently, they have no sense of being responsible for these people.
这并不是一个人们可能希望的那种整齐的比较，因为莫卧儿人——无论你采取印度右翼的观点，认为他们自1200年代起就生活在印度，认为他们就像18世纪英国的诺曼法国人一样是地道的印度人，认为他们已经完全融入印度，这里就是他们的家。他们长期统治，并投资于作为印度统治者所必须做的简单事情，比如粮仓，因为大家都知道季风每隔几年就会失灵，你需要储备粮食来养活你的人民。他们投资于各种国家所需的长期经济建设。东印度公司统治初期值得注意的一点是，正如你所暗示的，他们不仅利用莫卧儿的税收制度并从中榨取财富——他们确实做得非常高效——而且他们根本没有对这些人负责的意识。
There is no sense in which they are doing uh doing anything more than ruling them and they don't think it's their job so when for example we have this terrific famine which breaks out uh it's not that it's it's a worse famine than india's ever seen before it's just that no one has bothered making any grain stores or uh in company territory providing soup kitchens or uh right more than amazon would provide kitchens now it's it's yeah so in in in in luck now the same famine takes place but they uh the nawab gets everybody to uh to build an imam vara the which is still there this enormous white elephant of a building but you know people get basic pay they. They can buy themselves some food and they don't die. This is a Keynesian program. Exactly that.
他们完全没有意识到自己除了统治这些人之外还有其他责任，他们认为这不是他们的工作。所以，例如当这场可怕的饥荒爆发时，并不是说这场饥荒比印度以往见过的更严重，只是没有人费心去建立任何粮仓，或者在公司领地提供救济食堂，或者——就像亚马逊现在不会提供食堂一样。是的，在勒克瑙，同样的饥荒也发生了，但纳瓦布让每个人都去建造一座伊玛目巴拉（Imambara），那座至今仍矗立在那里的巨大的“白象”建筑，但你知道，人们能得到基本工资，他们可以买些食物，所以他们没有饿死。这是一个凯恩斯主义的计划。正是如此。
Right. Exactly. But the company doesn't do that. And it just lets a million people die. So you can draw a real distinction. They're both. It's quite true. Our exploitative systems, the mogul rule taxes very heavily.
没错。正是这样。但公司没有这样做。它只是任由一百万人死去。所以你可以划出一条真正的界限。它们都是——这确实是真的——剥削制度，莫卧儿统治的税收也非常沉重。
And in terms of straight tax probably taxed tiny bit more heavily even than the East India Company but the difference is that the they do very mogul see themselves as rulers and see themselves as having responsibilities as well as the perks of of ruling a very rich territory the company simply doesn't and everyone is young they're in their 20s they want to get back to England and and start a parliamentary career and it is any way they can just make a quick buck they tend to well that raises a good question willie that we've got from stefan jensen he says who who are these people so you said they're young they're in their 20s he says are they basically the equivalent of people working on apprenticeship elite apprenticeship schemes for
就纯税收而言，可能比东印度公司还要重一点点，但区别在于，莫卧儿人确实把自己视为统治者，认为自己在享受统治富饶领土的红利的同时也负有责任，而公司根本没有这种想法。每个人都很年轻，才20多岁，他们想回到英国开启议会生涯，任何能让他们快速赚钱的方法他们都愿意尝试。威利，这引出了一个好问题，斯蒂芬·詹森问：这些人到底是谁？你说他们很年轻，才20多岁，他问他们是否基本上相当于今天离开牛津剑桥后在精英学徒计划中为战略咨询公司和投资银行工作的人？
sort of strategic consultancies and investment banks today when they leave oxbridge or or are they are they people from the bottom who are working their way up or what are they exactly so in terms of class uh the perennial english question um they're mid they're middle upper rank but they're not the top um simply because so many people die in the east india. I mean, the simple fact is if you join the East India Company at the age of 16, which was the oldest you could join it. The oldest? They were literally the oldest.
还是说他们是来自底层、一步步往上爬的人？或者他们到底是什么人？就阶级而言——这是一个永恒的英国问题——他们属于中上阶层，但不是顶层。原因很简单，因为在东印度公司死亡的人太多了。我的意思是，简单的事实是，如果你在16岁时加入东印度公司，这已经是你能加入的最大年龄了。最大年龄？他们真的是最大的了。
They were taking kids of 15 and shipping them out. And then they spend a year or two in the writer's building learning accountancy and languages, and then off they go. And then they die. And most of them, if they can, are out by 30 or 35. And what's the death rate? Two-thirds. Goodness.
他们招收15岁的孩子并把他们送出去。然后他们在“文书大楼”（Writer's Building）花一两年时间学习会计和语言，然后就出发了。接着他们就死了。他们大多数人如果能活下来，30或35岁就离开了。死亡率是多少？三分之二。天哪。
Two-thirds die. Two-thirds die and one-third die the first year. Okay. So it's a massive carnage. And you go to those cemeteries in Calcutta, Park Street Cemetery, and there's these lines and lines of Georgian obelisks. And a lot of them die one or two years. A lot of them are children, some of them get married out there and their children just die.
三分之二的人死了。三分之二的人死亡，其中三分之一在第一年就死了。好吧。所以这是一场巨大的屠杀。你去加尔各答的公园街公墓，那里有一排排乔治亚时代的方尖碑。很多人死于一两年内。很多人是孩子，有些人去那里结婚，他们的孩子也死了。
As one English or Scottish sailor Alexander Hamilton puts it, they die like rotting sheep in Bengal. So if you were a top-top, if you were the Duke of Devonshire's son, you wouldn't join the East Indic Company. However, if you were from the background, my family, which we're from, which was provincial Scottish gentry whose income never quite matched their social aspirations. You pile in. This is absolutely where you send your younger brothers and younger sons in the hope that one of them will live long enough to make some money.
正如一位英国或苏格兰水手亚历山大·汉密尔顿所说，他们在孟加拉像腐烂的羊一样死去。所以，如果你是顶尖中的顶尖，如果你是德文郡公爵的儿子，你不会加入东印度公司。然而，如果你来自我家族那样的背景——省级的苏格兰乡绅，收入总是不太符合社会抱负——你就会挤进去。这绝对是你送弟弟和次子去的地方，希望他们中有人能活得足够长赚点钱。
And in the case of my wife's family, the Fraser six go out one comes back so willie this this attritional rate it means as you've said you said at the beginning of the episode um basically that there are very few british people out there and so and so when we look at clive who i guess is the the archetype of the self-made man who scams and tricks and strong arms his way to a position of incredible wealth. He wins the Battle of Plassey. He essentially conquers Bengal. He's doing that in association with a lot of Indian backers, right? I mean, it's not a kind of British takeover. It's an Anglo-Indian coup, essentially. So the crucial point about Plassey is that it's not just he's doing it in association with a lot of Indian backers. He is paid to do it by an Indian banker.
以我妻子的家族为例，弗雷泽家的六个人出去，只有一个回来。所以威利，这种损耗率意味着，正如你在本集开头所说，基本上在那里的英国人很少。所以当我们看克莱夫时，我想他是那种通过欺诈、诡计和强权手段获得惊人财富的“白手起家”者的原型。他赢得了普拉西战役。他基本上征服了孟加拉。他是在许多印度支持者的协助下完成的，对吧？我的意思是，这并不是一种英国式的接管。这本质上是一场英印政变。所以普拉西战役的关键点在于，他不仅是在许多印度支持者的协助下完成的。他是由一位印度银行家出钱让他去做的。
He hadn't thought of fighting Plassey. The story, in a nutshell, is that the Seven Year Wars is about to break out and the East India Company get given a dossier, a dodgy dossier, an intelligence dossier that turns out to be completely wrong. And some captain has seen a whole load of French ships loading cannon at Port Lorient and heading off and tells the East India Company it's heading to Bengal. In fact, it's heading to Canada. And that's where the Seven Year War in the end breaks out with a lot of sort of, you know, last of the Mohican stuff of war canoes crossing Lake Huron and all that sort of stuff, and scalping in top Washington state and all that sort of thing. But because of this, the East India Company goes to the Admiralty and says we've got a report saying that there's a huge French fleet going to attack Bengal and so they send out Robert Clive who has
他本来没想过要打普拉西战役。故事简而言之，七年战争即将爆发，东印度公司收到了一份档案，一份可疑的、后来证明完全错误的情报档案。有位船长看到一大批法国船只在洛里昂港装载大炮并出发，告诉东印度公司它们正前往孟加拉。事实上，它们是去加拿大的。而七年战争最终也是在那里爆发的，伴随着各种像《最后的莫希干人》那样的战争独木舟横渡休伦湖，以及在华盛顿州头皮剥离之类的东西。但正因为如此，东印度公司去海军部说我们收到报告称有一支庞大的法国舰队要攻击孟加拉，于是他们派出了罗伯特·克莱夫，他
already been out to India once before, made a name for himself as a rubbish accountant but an incredibly talented untrained soldier. He's this sort of weird extraordinary suicidal man who twice has failed to shoot himself through depression, but who then finds his métier in soldiering against the French. So he's the most lethal accountant in history, in a way. He's the most lethal accountant. I mean, there are many lethal accountants in the annals, but he's definitely the number one badass accountant.
之前已经去过一次印度，以糟糕的会计表现但极具天赋的非正规士兵身份而闻名。他是一个奇怪的、非凡的、有自杀倾向的人，曾两次因抑郁症试图自杀未遂，但后来在对抗法国人的战争中找到了自己的职业。所以从某种意义上说，他是历史上最致命的会计。他是最致命的会计。我的意思是，史册中有很多致命的会计，但他绝对是头号狠角色会计。
And he has this sort of suicidal tendency. He attacks at night in monsoon thunderstorms from the rear. And everything he does could so easily go wrong. And yet he has this amazing sense of how far he can push things, how to size up in Poland. When he's attacking, so he comes out to india finds there's no french fleet and you know it's an embarrassing situation but luckily the news comes that calcutta has fallen to the uh nawab suraj and dallas so he sails his his navy fleet of marines up to uh up
他有一种自杀倾向。他在季风雷雨之夜从后方发动攻击。他所做的一切都很容易出错。然而，他有一种惊人的直觉，知道事情能推进到什么程度，如何评估局势。当他进攻时，他来到印度发现根本没有法国舰队，你知道这很尴尬，但幸运的是，消息传来，加尔各答落入了纳瓦布·西拉杰·乌德·道拉手中，所以他带着海军陆战队舰队向上游航行，
to the hoogly and he takes calcutta back and he's about to go home and willie this is this is the black hole of calcutta incident this is is after the black hole of Calcutta. So Siraj has captured Calcutta from the British, bunged them in the black hole, or have they, you know, much debated, and then he retreats. Definitely, definitely there was a black hole. The question is how many died,
到达胡格利河，夺回了加尔各答，正准备回家。威利，这就是加尔各答黑洞事件，这是在加尔各答黑洞事件之后。所以西拉杰从英国人手中夺取了加尔各答，把他们塞进了黑洞——或者他们是这样说的，争议很大——然后他撤退了。绝对，绝对有黑洞这回事。问题是有多少人死了，
and estimates vary widely, whether it's 100 or whether it's just 60 or something, or 40. But however many died, and we'll never actually know the figure, Clive, by chance, because of this dodgy dossier, is on hand with a fleet. And rather than attacking the French, he turns it on Siraj, takes Calcutta, and is about to go home.
估计差异很大，是一百人，还是只有60人左右，或者是40人。但无论死了多少人，我们永远不会知道确切数字，克莱夫因为那份可疑的档案，恰好带着一支舰队在场。他没有去攻击法国人，而是转而对付西拉杰，夺取了加尔各答，并准备回家。
Job done. And at that point, and this is a crucial point that's often obfuscated in both English and Indian accounts of the battle, the jugger set, who is the big banker, who's invented a way of getting tax revenue from Bengal to Delhi without marching it out physically. In the old days, you'd take the tax revenue, put it on a line of 100 bullet carts and march it through UP to Delhi. But because Delhi and UP has now given way to anarchy, it's very difficult to get
任务完成。就在那时——这是一个在英印双方对战役的描述中经常被掩盖的关键点——贾格特·赛斯（Jagat Seth），那位大银行家，他发明了一种将孟加拉的税收收入运往德里而无需物理押运的方法。在过去，你会把税收收入装上100辆牛车，穿过北方邦运往德里。但由于德里和北方邦现在陷入无政府状态，很难将
the money through in a physical form. So the jagat set says, no problem, just deliver it to my office in Murshidabad, and you can draw it by credit in Delhi, and I will take 15%. Thank you very much. And because of the anarchy and because of the difficulty of getting finance there physically, the Mughal emperors do this,
钱以实物形式运过去。所以贾格特·赛斯说，没问题，只要把它送到我在穆尔希达巴德的办公室，你就可以在德里通过信贷提取，我会收取15%的费用。非常感谢。由于无政府状态和物理运输资金的困难，莫卧儿皇帝们就这样做了，
and 15% of the Bengal tax revenues go to this one banking. And so, Willie... They turn into... Just finish the story. So they turn into the Rothschilds of India, and it's those guys who write to Clive and say, don't go back to Madras quite yet. Finish the job, march up to Mashidabad,
孟加拉税收收入的15%流向了这家银行。所以，威利……他们变成了……把故事讲完。所以他们变成了印度的罗斯柴尔德家族，正是这些人写信给克莱夫说，别急着回马德拉斯。完成任务，向穆尔希达巴德进军，
two days days march from Calcutta and kill Siraj Udawla. And I will pay you personally, Robert McClive, one million pounds and I will pay the East India Company a further one million pounds. And Clive says, thank you very much. He doesn't ask anyone. He doesn't write to Madras. It's a totally different mission to the one he'd been sent on, but he goes and does it. And once he's in there and Siraj is dead he marches into the machida bad treasury and literally fills first his pockets and then 60 barges with gold which are then punted downstream to fort william when he's asked later uh by the
从加尔各答出发两天的路程，杀了西拉杰·乌德·道拉。我会亲自付给你，罗伯特·克莱夫，一百万英镑，我还会再付给东印度公司一百万英镑。克莱夫说，非常感谢。他没有问任何人。他没有写信给马德拉斯。这与他被派去执行的任务完全不同，但他还是去了并完成了。一旦他进入那里，西拉杰死了，他走进穆尔希达巴德的国库，先是装满了自己的口袋，然后装满了60艘驳船的黄金，这些黄金随后被运往威廉堡。当他后来被
parliamentary inquiry uh why he just felt he could do this he said my lords i was astonished my own moderation so what's fascinating about this story is that there's a there seems to be a kind of anglo-indian synergy so you've got clive basically behaving like you know like nadir shah i mean he's basically doing exactly the same correct um but you also you have you know, we know that capitalism is developing in England and Britain, and the East India Company is kind of riding that wave. But clearly, you also have capitalism emerging in India, you've got these kind of proto Bitcoin kind of developing in India so so what's other is it British capitalism that's interviews that's um influencing the way that Indian merchants operate or is it Indian merchants that are influencing how the British operate or are they kind of fusing to create this hybrid Anglo-Indian form of of capitalism so so what you've got is is two groups of bankers speaking the same language
议会调查委员会问及为什么他觉得可以这样做时，他说：大人，我对自己（竟然如此）克制感到惊讶。所以这个故事最迷人之处在于，似乎存在一种英印协同效应。所以克莱夫的行为基本上就像纳迪尔沙一样，我的意思是，他基本上做的完全一样。没错。但你也有，我们知道资本主义正在英国和不列颠发展，东印度公司正乘着那股浪潮。但显然，印度也出现了资本主义，印度正在发展出类似比特币的原型。所以，是英国资本主义在影响印度商人的运作方式，还是印度商人在影响英国人的运作方式？或者他们正在融合，创造出这种混合的英印资本主义形式？所以你拥有的是两组说着同一种语言的银行家
to each other and although one lot are vegetarian Hindus Hindus and Jains originally from Jodhpur state, the Mawaris, who are this the Mawaris are the kind of uber bankers of India, even today, they own something like 25 percent of Indian capital. There's only a handful of them and a lot of the big houses, a lot of the big business houses in india to this day are more worried um and so the the jagat sets want business as usual and they're making a fortune lending money to people like the east india company the dutch east india company and the portuguese and the danes and the french and siraj down the raid in calcutta is not just a threat to the east india
在交流，尽管其中一群是素食主义的印度教徒和耆那教徒，最初来自焦特布尔邦，即马瓦里人（Mawaris），他们是印度的超级银行家，即使在今天，他们也拥有印度约25%的资本。他们只有少数人，而印度今天许多大企业集团都是马瓦里人。所以贾格特·赛斯希望一切照旧，他们通过借钱给东印度公司、荷兰东印度公司、葡萄牙人、丹麦人和法国人赚了一大笔钱。西拉杰在加尔各答的突袭不仅是对东印度
company it's a threat to the juggernauts so say, we've got to get rid of this complete psychopath, Siraj Adana, who clearly, incidentally, British propaganda against Siraj Adana is not just British propaganda against Siraj Adana, he was clearly a complete psycho. And the Mughal accounts and French accounts and everyone's accounts make this clear. So Jagat Seth paid for the East India Company to use its military force on Indians for the first time. And from that point, not just the Jagat Seths, but other Indian bankers continue to pour their finances to the East India Company. Why?
公司的威胁，也是对贾格特·赛斯的威胁。所以他们说，我们必须除掉这个彻头彻尾的疯子西拉杰·乌德·道拉，顺便说一句，英国针对西拉杰·乌德·道拉的宣传不仅仅是英国的宣传，他显然是个彻头彻尾的疯子。莫卧儿的记录、法国的记录以及所有人的记录都清楚地表明了这一点。所以贾格特·赛斯出钱让东印度公司第一次对印度人使用武力。从那时起，不仅是贾格特·赛斯，其他印度银行家也继续向东印度公司注入资金。为什么？
Because the East India Company are businessmen. They understand the conception of interest and repaying on time and the uh gradations of uh of incremental uh uh interest that you must pay if you're late and so on while if you're lending state to a maratha warlord and you ask for your money back he's quite likely to hang you up by your heels and and and and beat you to death and so there's a very clear mutual understanding of mutual interests going on between indian bankers and the company and they are you know they're the same sort of people talking the same sort of language and they all make a huge profit together willie i want to ask a question because you're talking about the seven years war and how this happens in the context of the seven years
因为东印度公司是商人。他们理解利息的概念，理解按时还款，理解如果你迟还款必须支付的增量利息等等。而如果你把钱借给马拉塔军阀，你要求还钱时，他很可能会把你倒挂起来，把你活活打死。所以印度银行家和公司之间存在着非常明确的共同利益理解，他们是同类人，说着同一种语言，他们一起赚取了巨额利润。威利，我想问一个问题，因为你谈到了七年战争，以及这如何在七年战争的背景下发生，
war and that raises an excellent question which michael priest sent in on twitter he says if the east india company didn't exist or if it had been slower to grasp these opportunities, would another European competitor, let's say the French or the Dutch, particularly the French, I guess, since we're in the late 18th century, would not they have moved in and done precisely the same thing? The answer is quite possibly. The Dutch are kind of out of the picture by the time of Classy. They're still around in Indonesia, but that is certainly no longer the great
这引出了迈克尔·普里斯特在推特上发来的一个绝佳问题。他说，如果东印度公司不存在，或者如果它对这些机会的把握较慢，会有另一个欧洲竞争对手，比如法国或荷兰——特别是法国，我想，因为我们处于18世纪末——会介入并做同样的事情吗？答案是很有可能。到普拉西战役时，荷兰人基本上已经出局了。他们还在印度尼西亚，但那肯定不再是荷兰东印度公司（VOC）的辉煌时代了。作为一支军事力量，他们实际上并不存在。但法国人确实还在，而且他们的商业运作效率比英国东印度公司低，因为他们受凡尔赛宫廷控制。凡尔赛宫廷并不真正了解商业。但东印度公司是由一群确实了解金融和利润的商人经营的。因此，
days of the VOC. And as a military force, they don't really exist. But the French very much are around and they are less efficient business operation than the English East India Company because they're controlled by the court in Versailles. And the court in Versailles doesn't really understand business. But the East India Company is just run by a bunch of merchants who do understand finance and profit. And therefore
它对经济需求的反应比法国东印度公司要快得多，后者始终是一个政治运作机构。克莱夫能迅速行动，而法国人可能更害怕，是因为宫廷或其他原因吗？不是这样，因为你很早就有了这些——我的意思是，克莱夫在1740年代（普拉西战役前十年）的第一次胜利就是针对这些非常机智的法国人，其中一人是德洛里斯顿勋爵的儿子，他最初建立了整个法国东印度公司，并创建了整个法国银行网络。其中最有趣的人物之一，最初是一个苏格兰人，因一场关于荣誉问题的决斗逃离苏格兰，成为了法国的大银行家。去年有一本詹姆斯·布坎写的精彩传记。他的儿子是克莱夫在1740年代卡纳蒂克战争中的对手，法国人在那里运作得非常高效。所以是的，很有可能，如果克莱夫不存在，如果德洛里斯顿勋爵掌握了局面，那么现在法语会是印度的通用语言，而且孟加拉俱乐部的食物可能比现在供应的棕色温莎汤要好一些。
it responds to economic need much more readily than the French East India Company which is always a political operation. And is it also that Clive can act quickly in a way that maybe a frenchman would be more frightened because the court or something not the case because you get these i mean get these early on i mean clive's first victories in the 1740s a decade before classy are against these very quick-witted um frenchmen one of whom is the son of lord Deloriston, who sets up the whole French East
好吧，我记得去本地治里吃过羊角面包。所以那里有一点点可能性的瞥见。但威利，把那个问题扩大一点。所以英国人基本上吞并了孟加拉。然后，军事参与的下一个主要焦点——此时公司意识到他们可以招募军队——是他们在印度南部的迈索尔遇到了蒂普苏丹，他是一个火箭狂热者。多米尼克，我们刚才在谈论康格里夫火箭，康格里夫火箭。蒂普苏丹，他基本上
Indy Company in the first place, and who creates the whole French banking network. And one of the most interesting figures, a Scotsman originally, who fled Scotland after a duel over a point of honour, and becomes the big French banker. There's a fantastic James Buchan biography last year. His son is the adversary of Clive in the 1740s, the Carnatic Wars, and the French operate very efficiently there. So yes, there is a strong possibility that had Clive not existed and had the Lord of the Loristons had the run of the game, that you'd now have French as the spoken language of India and maybe rather better food in the Bengal clubs than the Brown Windsor soup, which is still served.
对于印度南部的印度教徒来说，他们深受无政府状态、敌对军阀等困扰。英国人和蒂普苏丹之间有什么区别？他们都是一神论者。统治者是谁对他们来说有区别吗？所以，从某种意义上说，这是印度人50年来一直在问的伟大问题之一，根据你所处的政治光谱，你会得到完全不同的答案。对于左翼、尼赫鲁派来说，蒂普是这片土地的儿子，他的祖先在印度可能已经生活了700年或600年，
Well, I remember going to Pondicherry and having a croissant. So a little glimpse there of what might have been. But Willie, just to broaden that question out. So the British basically annex Bengal. And then the next kind of major focus for military engagement by this point the company realized that they can recruit armies is that they come up against tippu sultan in mysore in the south of india who's a great enthusiast for rockets dominic we were talking about congreve rockets congreve rockets tippu sultan who basically
他和其他人一样是印度人。然而，如果你问像斯瓦潘·达斯·古普塔（Swapandas Gupta）这样的印度右翼历史学家，他会说，不，他们是外来者。他们向往麦加。或者V.S.奈保尔对印度穆斯林的态度。他们不是完全的印度人。他们以某种方式不同。这就是今天印度的大辩论。印度穆斯林是印度的一部分吗？还是不是？尼赫鲁派说是的，他们是。印度人民党（BJP）和国民志愿服务团（RSS）说他们不是。RSS的创始人将他们比作欧洲的闪米特少数群体——犹太人，我们必须做，戈尔瓦尔卡（Golwalkar）说，我们国家定义了最初的RSS政策文件，如果你愿意的话，我们必须对我们的少数群体做
um for for the hindus say in southern india who were afflicted by the kind of anarchy, by rival warlords, whatever. What's the difference between the British and Tipu Sultan? They're both monotheists. Does it make any difference to them who the ruler is? So this is, in a sense, one of the great questions that Indians have asked for 50 years and you get completely different answers depending on which end of the political spectrum you are. For a leftist, Nauruvian, Tipu is a son of the soil whose ancestors have been in India for you know possibly 700 years or 600 years by this
德国人对他们的少数群体在“水晶之夜”所做的事情。但威利，就18世纪末、19世纪初而言，当大多数印度教徒印度人看着穆斯林、穆斯林苏丹或英国基督教公司官员时，他们会觉得，不，我们不能接受英国人，因为他们是完全的外国人吗？还是说，只要统治者提供一定程度的稳定、一定程度的安全，谁来统治其实并不重要？这就是东印度公司最终能够建立统治的原因吗？因为足够多的印度人愿意接受它作为安全保障者，无论他们多么贪婪，因为基本上，你知道，印度农民习惯了被
stage and who is as Indian as anyone else. However, if you ask a historian like Swapandas Gupta on the Hindu right, you'll say, no, they are outsiders. They look to Mecca. Or V.S. Naipaul's attitude to Indian Muslims. They're not fully Indian. They're somehow different. And this is the big debate in India today. Are Indian Muslims part of India or are they not? And the Nauruvians say yes they are. The BJP and the RSS say they're not. The founder of the RSS compares them to the Semitic minority in Europe, the Jews, and we must do, says Goelka, and we our nation have defined the original RSS policy document, if you like, we must do to our minority
几个世纪以来一直如此。所以如果问我的意见，我的意见是，对于一个印度人来说，被东印度公司统治和被蒂普苏丹统治有巨大的区别。是的，两者对印度教徒来说都是不同的宗教，但蒂普苏丹在文化上已经成为印度的一部分。如果你今天去卡纳塔克邦，尽管他有在王国之外摧毁敌人寺庙的名声，但迈索尔周围所有的寺庙都有他们所谓的“Pajcha Lingams”，这是蒂普苏丹赠送给迈索尔、卡纳塔克邦和泰米尔纳德邦各大寺庙的。所以我认为这不一样。
what the Germans did to theirs at Kristallnacht. But Willie, in terms of the 18th century, late 18th century, beginnings of the 19th century, the mass of Indians who are Hindu, when they look at Muslims, Muslim sultans or British Christian company officers, do they feel, no, we can't have the British because they are completely foreign? Or does it not really make any difference who their rulers is, as long as the rulers are providing a measure of stability, a measure of security? And is that why the East England Company is able to establish its rule ultimately is that enough indians are willing to accept it as as basically the kind of the guarantee the guarantor of security no matter how rapacious they may be because basically you know indian peasantry are used to being
但你问题的第二部分，人们为了稳定而支持公司是真的吗？毫无疑问，是的。尤其是商人阶层。贾格特·赛斯并不孤单。整个商业印度都在持续向公司贷款，而不是借给蒂普或马拉塔人，尽管马拉塔人是同一个宗教。例如，马拉塔人在1740年代冲进孟加拉，对他们认为是莫卧儿领土的地方进行了大量的掠夺和抢劫，尽管那里的大多数人是印度教徒。这就是导致加尔各答发展的主要原因之一，因为加尔各答，曾经是一个小商人殖民地，在1740年代规模巨大，因为它有现在仍被称为“马拉塔沟”（Maratha Ditch）的东西。它现在是一条环路，但它是公司挖掘的用来保护加尔各答免受马拉塔人攻击的沟渠。马拉塔人从未攻击过加尔各答。所以这也是许多马瓦里银行家从拉贾斯坦邦搬到孟加拉的时候。除此之外，公司在加尔各答建立了一个有点像今天迪拜的制度，基本上富人如果把财富投资在殖民地，就可以免税。所以你看到大量银行家从北印度涌向加尔各答，以避税并受到英国枪炮的保护。
that's the kind of standard for centuries and centuries so if i'm asking my my opinion um my opinion is that there is a huge difference for an indian between being ruled by uh the east india company and tippu sultan um yes both are different religion to the hindus but tippu sultan's culturally become part of India. If you go around Karnataka today, although he has a reputation for having destroyed temples of his enemies outside his kingdoms, all the temples around Mysore have what they call Pajcha Lingams, which were given by Tipu Sultan to the great temples across Mysore and Karnataka and Tamil Nadu. So I don't think it's the same.
所以，尽管这在某种意义上解释了我们觉得很难理解的事情——为什么这么多印度人会通过成为雇佣兵或借钱给这家贪婪、激进的外国公司来违背我们所认为的印度国家利益——人们这样做是因为它保护了他们，因为他们可以从中赚钱，即使这意味着各种王朝的毁灭
But the second part of your question, is it true that people back the company for stability? Unquestionably, yes. And that's particularly the merchant class. The jagat sets are not alone. There is a whole swathe of business India that consistently lends to the company in preference to lending to Tipu or the Marathas, even though the Marathas are the same religion. And the Marathas, for example, burst through Bengal in the 1740s and do a lot of looting and plundering of what
和对不幸者的掠夺。如果你是一个富有的商人，你可以通过与公司联手、借钱给他们来赚钱，并带着巨额财富退休，英国人协助商人阶层从莫卧儿贵族手中剥夺这些财富，并将其交给新兴的银行和商人阶层。好吧，威利，我们的时间不多了，所以……告诉我，我不相信本·麦金泰尔会对你说你插不上话。我的意思是，那绝对是。如果他真的说了，我得说你已经彻底证明他错了。
they regard as Mughal territory, even though the majority of the people there are Hindu. And this is one of the big things that leads to the growth of Calcutta, because Calcutta, which had been a small merchant colony, grows enormously in the 1740s because it has what is still called the Maratha Ditch. It's now a ring road, but it was the ditch dug by the company to protect Calcutta against the Marathas. And the Marathas never attacked Calcutta. So that's also the point at which a lot of the Mawari bankers moved from Rajasthan to Bengal. And on top of this, the company establishes in Calcutta a system a bit like Dubai today, where basically rich people can go tax-free if they invest their wealth in the colony. And so you get this huge hemorrhage of bankers from North India moving to Calcutta to avoid taxes and to be protected by British guns.
缩小的飞行员。那么出了什么问题？出了什么问题？东印度公司在那里。它赚了很多钱。它有合作者。你知道，印度生活照常进行。如果你是东印度公司的人，一切看起来都很美好。
So although it's a very, in a sense that explains the difficult thing for us, which we find so hard to understand, how so many Indians could act against what we presume to be Indian national interests by becoming a sepoy or lending money to this this rapacious greedy aggressive foreign company uh people people went to it because it protected them and because uh they could make money out of it even though the it might mean the destruction of various dynasties
19世纪中期出了什么问题？所以有两件事出了问题。首先，18世纪末出了问题。在普拉西战役之后，你对孟加拉进行了如此全面的资产剥离。普拉西战役是1756年，巴克萨战役是1765年，这两场伟大的公司胜利使得北印度没有有效的反对力量来对抗公司。在那一点上，这些人只是字面上……他们剥离了所有能剥离的东西。他们开始把织工关进某种纺织集中营，据一个来源称，
and the looting of of the unlucky if you were a rich merchant you could make your money by joining hands with the company lending the money and uh and retire with with huge fortunes which which the the british assist the merchant classes in stripping from the mogul aristocracy and giving to the new the new rising banking and and merchant classes okay willie we're running out of time a bit so um tell me what what go i don't believe believe that Ben McIntyre said to you that you wouldn't get a word in Hedgeways. I mean, that's definitely it. And if he did, you've proved him comprehensively wrong, I will say.
他们开始切断自己的拇指，这样他们就没用了，不能织布，从而逃避这种奴隶制。当1770年饥荒爆发，根据你采用的账户，有一百万人到六百万人死亡，大概是两百万左右，公司实际上破产了。这家看起来“大到不能倒”的公司，意味着在饥荒期间，通过那些牟取暴利的个人公司人员，将巨额资金（数百万）汇回国内。在1772年，即1770年到1772年之间，公司彻底破产了。他们首先去找刚刚成立的英格兰银行，但它没有足够的钱来拯救它。
Shrinking pilot. So what goes wrong, right? What goes wrong? The East India Company is there. It's making tons of money. It's got collaborators. You know, life goes on in India. If you're an East India Company man, all seems rosy.
所以发生的事情是，议会召开了会议，你得到了和戈登·布朗在2008年银行倒闭后对国民西敏寺银行（NatWest）所做的一样的事情，它基本上把东印度公司从终极的自由意志主义、自由市场、经济海盗变成了某种公私合营企业。所以到1774年，在《监管法案》中，公司有一半由英国政府拥有。
What goes wrong in the mid-19th century? So two things go wrong. First of all, something goes wrong in the late 18th century. You get such comprehensive asset stripping of bengal after plastic and baxter classy is 1756 baxter in 1765 these two great company victories leaving no effective opposition in north india to the company and at that point these guys just literally uh just just you know they strip everything that isn't that can. They start locking weavers up in sort of weaving concentration camps so that allegedly, according to one source,
这就是国家参与公司的开始，这种参与在19世纪不断增加，以至于到1830年代，公司根本不再作为商业组织运作，它变得像一个管理公司，有点像BBC。BBC征服媒体的想法。经营一个海盗式的。它是最后的公司。强迫人们制作糟糕的第四电台喜剧节目。字面上，授予公司的同一个公司章程仍然由BBC持有。这完全是同样的国家机制。
they start cutting their own thumbs off so that they're useless, can't weave and can escape this sort of slavery. And when the 1770 famine breaks out and between one and six million people die according to whose accounts you take probably around two million uh the company actually goes bankrupt this company that had seemed too big to fail which means sending vast sums of money home millions are exported during the famine by individual company men who've made profits profiteering. And in 1772, between 1770 and 1772, the company goes properly bankrupt. They first go to the Bank of England, which is just set up, and doesn't have enough money to save it.
惊人的想法。对公司来说，它仍然由BBC持有，这完全是同样的国家机制。好吧，无论如何，所以……所以逐渐进入19世纪，公司越来越少关注贸易，越来越多关注政府。然后，由于1820年代和1830年代伟大的福音派繁荣期间，公司将军们日益增长的福音派传教活动，苹果车被掀翻了。克拉珀姆派（Clapham sect）和所有这些快乐的福音派教徒来到印度，开始向阅兵场上的雇佣兵宣读圣经，他们都是优秀的婆罗门素食主义者，不想被告知关于吃基督身体的事情。在这非常短暂的时期，大约20年的很短时期，公司突然拥抱了福音派基督教，主要是通过一个叫查尔斯·格兰特的人，他是主要的福音派教徒，成为了公司的董事。而这
So what happens is that Parliament meets, and you get the same thing as Gordon Brown did for NatWest after the 2008 bank collapses, it basically turns the East India Company from the ultimate libertarian, free market, economic buccaneer into a sort of public-private partnership. So by 1774, in the Regulating Act, the company is half owned by the British state.
导致了大规模的反殖民起义，我们在英国仍然称之为“印度兵变”，而在印度被称为“第一次独立战争”。无论你怎么称呼它。两者基本上都不准确。是的，我的意思是，我在《最后的莫卧儿》中称之为“大起义”，因为它是一场兵变，但它也得到了某些地方（如勒克瑙）的大量人口的加入，然后部落群体和各种各样的人都加入了。1857年爆发了
And that's the beginning of state involvement in the company, which increases towards the 19th century so that by the 1830s the company's not really functioning as a merchant organization at all it's become like a governing corporation rather like the BBC uh the idea of the BBC conquering the media. Running a piratical. It is the last of the corporations. Forcing people to make terrible Radio 4 comedy shows. Literally, the same charter of corporation which is given to the company is still held by the BBC. It's exactly the same mechanism of state.
世界上任何地方在任何时候发生的最大规模的反殖民起义，成千上万的人死亡，这是一场彻底的血腥混乱。英国在印度的人口在开始时被屠杀了很多，北印度的印度人口在随后的报复中被屠杀了很多。议会在1858年召开会议说，受够了。很多人一直在说，你知道，把最好的殖民地交给一群坐在伦敦城的商人来经营，这是一种荒谬的方式。显然，人们一直在议会里非常大声地这样说。快速插话，快速插话，在开头你说英国人没有占领
Amazing thought. to the company it is still held by the BBC it's exactly the same mechanism of state okay anyway the so the so the gradually into the 19th century the company becomes less and less about trade and more and more about government and then uh the apple cart is overturned due to the increasing evangelical proselytization uh of of company generals during the great evangelical boom of the 1820s and 1830s. And the Clapham sect and all these happy, clappy evangelicals come out to India and start reading the Bible to see boys on parade who are all good Brahmin vegetarians who do not want to be told about eating the body of Christ. And for this very brief period, and it is a very short period of about 20 years, the company suddenly embraces evangelical Christianity, largely through somebody called Charles Grant, who's a leading evangelical, becomes the director of the company. And this
印度，东印度公司占领了。所以这不是英国的事情，但你刚才说这是经营我们最好的殖民地的一种荒谬方式。那么态度改变了吗？人们现在认为现实已经改变了，因为公司，这个在200年里一直是自由意志主义自由市场的东西，在最后50年里确实越来越成为一个政府机构。总督是由议会任命的。所以韦尔斯利勋爵（Lord Wellesley），例如，讨厌公司，认为它是一群奶酪制造商。永远不要相信奶酪制造商，就像亚历克斯·詹姆斯一样。
leads to the massive anti-colonial uprising that we in this country still call the Indian Mutiny, and which in India is known as the First War of Independence. Whatever you call it. Both of which are inaccurate, basically. Yeah, I mean, I call it, in The Last Mogul, which deals with this, I call it the Great Uprising, because it is a mutiny, but it's also joined by large swathes of population in certain places like that now and then tribal groups and all sorts of people jump aboard and in 1857 there breaks
永远不要相信奶酪制造商。所以韦尔斯利是一个迷人的人物，因为他是一个年轻、雄心勃勃的议员，威灵顿公爵的哥哥，他来到这里决心利用东印度公司（一家公司）的军队来满足英国国家的需求。所以他利用它来攻击法国在印度的利益，尽管董事们说，
out the largest anti-colonial revolt to take place anywhere in the world at any point and hundreds of thousands of people die and it's complete bloody mess a lot of the British population in India slaughtered at the beginning a lot of the british population in india slaughtered at the beginning a lot of the indian population of north india slaughtered in the retribution which follows and parliament meets in 1858 and says enough's enough lots of people have been saying you know this is a ridiculous way to run your best colony to hand it over to a bunch of merchants sitting in the city of london clearly it's a people been saying this right very loudly in parliament quick interjection quick interjection at the beginning you said the british didn't take
不，不，不，不，我们不想要这个，我们只想要和平贸易，我们想要盈利。韦尔斯利否决了他们，使公司破产，花费了巨额现金，大量借贷，顺便说一句，还建造了巨大的建筑，比如总督府，一座仿照凯德尔斯顿（Kedleston）建造的宫殿。这是一个如此奇怪的故事，这是一个如此奇怪的故事……所以我认为……我想我们已经
india the east india company did so it wasn't a british thing but there you just said this is a ridiculous way to run our best colony so have attitudes changed then and people now think the reality has changed because the company which was this libertarian free market thing for 200 years, in its last 50 years does become increasingly a government agency. And the governor general is appointed by Parliament. So Lord Wellesley, for example, hates the company and regards it as a bunch of cheesemakers. Never trust a cheesemaker, like Alex James.
然后它在1858年被国有化了。它被国有化了。它变成了英属印度（Raj）。但那种奇怪的事情是，英属印度，它是如此出名，你知道
Never trust a cheesemaker. And so Wellesley is a fascinating figure because he's a young, ambitious parliamentarian, the elder brother of the Duke of Wellington, and he comes out determined to use the army of the East India Company, a corporation, for the British state needs. So he uses it to attack French interests in India, even though the director said,
并且占据了英国周日晚上的电视剧，我们都知道吉卜林和……但英属印度只持续了90年。是的。
no, no no no no we don't want this we just want a peaceful trade we want to make a profit and wellesley overrules them and bankrupts the company spends a vast quantity of cash borrows massively and also incidentally builds massive buildings like the governor general's house a palace modeled on kettleston it's such an odd story it's it's such an odd story It's such an odd story It's such an odd story So I think I mean I think we've
它甚至没有持续一个世纪。它始于1858年，1947年被废除。我们忘记了更长的时间是印度由一家私人公司从伦敦的一个办公室经营的250年。好吧，威利，非常感谢。我不认为听这个节目的任何人会有任何借口不去欣赏英国统治印度那种令人震惊的方式。我的意思是，这是一个惊人的故事，你讲得非常精彩。
And then it's nationalised 1858 It's nationalised And it becomes the Raj But the kind of weird thing Is that the Raj Which is so famous You know
你的四本书，《无政府状态》、《白人莫卧儿》、《国王归来》、《最后的莫卧儿》，即“公司四部曲”，现已出版。如果你还没读过，一定要买。非常感谢。我们下周会回来，不记得是什么内容，但是一些历史性的东西，可能是一些历史性的东西。我想这是一个合理的猜测。我们想要贵妇，我们想要贵妇和英国……哦，我们已经有了，我们做过了，我们做过了。你显然没有在听，你显然没有在听我们自己的……赶上积压的节目，威利，有一场足球锦标赛正在进行，那些……所有的笑话都已经……
And has occupied Sunday night dramas In Britain And we all know about Kipling and the But the Raj Only lasts 90 years Yeah
我们是老笑话。汤姆，你那天晚上总是那么容易在推特上发布。我非常失望。这一切都进入了播客。这里没有浪费任何东西。威利，非常感谢。我们很快会见到大家。再见。
It doesn't even make a century. It started 1858, it's abolished 1947. And we've forgotten that the much longer period is the 250 years when India is run by a private corporation out of one office in London. Well, Willie, thank you so much. I don't think anyone listening to this will have any excuse for not appreciating the astonishing way in which British rule came to India. I mean, it is an amazing story and you tell it brilliantly.
再见。感谢收听《历史的其余部分》（The Rest Is History）。如需奖励剧集、抢先收听、无广告收听以及访问我们的聊天社区，请在 restishistorypod.com 注册。那是 restishistorypod.com。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。
Your four books, The Anarchy, White Moguls, Return of the King, The Last Mogul, The Company Quartet, out now. Do buy them if you haven't read them. Thanks so much. We will be back next week can't remember what with but something historical something probably historical it's a it's a fair hunch i think we want dames we want dames and english oh we've had that we've done that we've done that you're clearly not listening you're clearly not listening to our own catch up with the backlog willy there's a football tournament going on those All those gags had already been...
你的四本书《无政府状态》、《白人莫卧儿》、《国王的回归》、《最后的莫卧儿》，即“公司四部曲”，现已出版。如果你还没读过，一定要买来看看。非常感谢。我们下周会回来，虽然我不记得要讲什么了，但肯定是关于历史的，大概是历史相关的，我觉得这是一个合理的猜测。我想我们要讲女士，我们要讲英国女士。哦，我们已经讲过了，我们做过了，我们做过了。你显然没在听，你显然没在听我们自己的节目。去补补之前的节目吧，威利，现在正有足球锦标赛呢。那些所有的笑话都已经……
We're old gags. You always had it so readily on your Twitter feed that night, Tom. I'm very disappointed. It's all gone into the podcast. Nothing goes to waste here. Willie, thanks so much. And we will see you all soon. Bye-bye.
我们是老笑话了。那天晚上你在推特上总是那么快地发布，汤姆。我很失望。所有的内容都进了播客。这里没有什么是浪费的。威利，非常感谢。我们很快会再见到大家。再见。
Bye-bye. Thanks for listening to The Rest Is History. For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening, and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
再见。感谢收听《历史的余味》。如需收听奖励剧集、抢先收听、无广告收听以及加入我们的聊天社区，请在restishistorypod.com注册。网址是restishistorypod.com。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。